wonder i haven't seen the full interview
of chris sims and josh allen i wonder if
josh allen is aware that sims has picked
the ravens to beat the bills this
weekend i wonder if that came up
yesterday
both
we both probably forgot to mention that
we both believe
that the ravens are going to win this
game and you may disagree with me we'll
get into that right now but you know two
of the hottest teams in the nfl down the
stretch the ravens had to win five
straight to punch their ticket to the
postseason the bills coming out of their
bye week following the hail murray
debacle have been unstoppable but they
got grazed by the colts last week their
defense was shredded by philip rivers
jonathan taylor and company and it was
josh allen who had to step up and
basically save the day so um this one
i'd be very nervous about it if i'm a
bills fan because the ravens with that
three-headed monster running the ball
with
marquis hollywood brown more involved in
the passing game and sims showed all
week long how they're throwing outside
the numbers something they hadn't done
all year
the the ravens to me
are are a very very challenging opponent
for the bills almost as challenging as
the chiefs will be if the bills get past
baltimore and if kansas city gets past
cleveland peter
i i agree with you mike but there's one
thing i would be concerned about
basically and that is
you know can
the baltimore ravens
play with
a
tennessee-like
uh intensity
in this game uh because
i you know i have to tell you i told
this to uh calais campbell uh after the
game the other day i said you know i
added it up you've played 247
college and pro football games in your
life
i and i've never seen you
and your defensive
uh partners
play a more intense football game either
in arizona or here
and i don't really remember watching all
that many jaguars games of his
but what i do rem and the first thing he
said was you're very right
i mean
there was something about that game last
week that was almost you know and i hate
to call it
personal because i think that's a little
cliche and silly but they hate the ten
the ravens hate the titans hate them
they don't so it is personal
it's cliche it's silly and it's accurate
so
apparently so but it just it's silly to
me i mean i can't imagine that if uh if
if if marcus peters
uh sees uh derek henry on the street
this offseason he's not going to
you know hug him or something like that
or whatever he's certainly not going to
punch him in the nose because derek
henry would kind of whip him yeah but
but
i think
you have to ask yourself
i think it's been a good thing
since that weird wednesday afternoon
game
in early december
when i believe and i think a lot of
people around the ravens believe mike
that game was really good for them
when you've got your third string
quarterback trace mcsorley
in the game
down the stretch throwing a td bomb to
hollywood brown and then having the ball
in your hands and having one last chance
to win a game against the big bad
undefeated steelers when that happens
and you and you give them everything
they want and you don't have most of
your many of your guys
i think that showed the ravens look
we're not dead
and just because every game down the
stretch is a playoff game for us now it
doesn't mean we're finished
and they have played you're right mike
they've played six consecutive games
where basically losing you're out
you know and you get to stay in
and they've been terrific so i i would i
would be afraid
you know of that kind of attitude i just
wonder if you can muster up that same
kind of intensity that they had in
nashville last weekend
and i think they can because this is
game number seven because they've been
living on the edge because they are used
to it they like it they like being in
this position i think for me and and i
agree with you it started on that
wednesday afternoon against pittsburgh
and i think it really became
permanent and galvanized on that monday
night that epic monday night game
against the browns where they somehow
found a way to win that's when you start
to think something special is going on
outsiders think it insiders think it and
they keep riding it and you don't do
that special night justice by falling
flat on your face later you have to
finish the job you have to pay it off so
that monday night will be remembered as
the moment where the 2020 ravens
became a championship caliber team and
you know we see it every year not every
single year but most years there's a
team this is kind of hovering there's a
team that's almost out of it there's a
team that's got maybe one more loss to
give before it's done it's right around
thanksgiving and then all of a sudden it
starts to fall together and it's win
after win after win and they carry that
momentum into the postseason and
actually
it's
it's good the bills played last week
because i think the ravens would have an
even better opportunity to catch them
flat-footed if the bills had a week off
and had not played a playoff game
because at least they played they won
and they've survived and they moved to
the next level they didn't just they
didn't just get a pass to the next level
uh but they still are dealing with the
ravens team that one on the road
that somehow
uh was favorites on the road and that
didn't give the titans the proverbial
chip on the shoulder they still overcame
that edge that went to the other team
and they got it done and even though
they'd lost twice in a row to the titans
there is that that that acrimony with
the titans i think they'll they'll
they'll find a way to whip themselves up
into a frenzy as it relates to the the
buffalo bills just because they they uh
they don't want to
um fail after coming so far and working
so hard to get to this point that's why
i think the ravens are going to pull off
and just from a football standpoint when
you look at what happened to the bills
defense last week peter
i i i
i i don't see them being able to slow
down what the ravens do the ravens are
capable of running it now they can throw
it and and i think the bills are going
to be stretched very thin
so the ravens have to hope that there
isn't this lake effect snow obviously
you don't want to have a slippery track
because on offense to me
the biggest danger point
for baltimore uh in this game the way
that they can really threaten the
buffalo defense
is for
uh is is for lamar jackson to play the
way he played last week in nashville and
here's the reason why mike
you know that game was anybody's game
until lamar jackson took off up the
middle uh
you know beaming toward the right pylon
diving getting in right at the end
and
i just thought at that moment
i'm one of these guys who say james
don't expose lamar jackson as much to
all these big defensive hits you know
make him stay back in the pocket tell
him listen
six eight times a game to run is plenty
but let's not be running 12 to 14 times
a game and lamar jackson rightfully so
says bunk
that is the way
i play football
and you don't want to strip a guy of
what he does best you don't want to make
him do the things that would make him a
b quarterback with doing something the
other way and doing it in a lot of
different ways can make him an a
quarterback
so
mike i've come to this realization and i
don't know how you feel
let's say lamar jackson does get beat up
some in the next few years and he only
has 11 peak seasons all right i'd rather
have 11 peak seasons than 16 seasons of
b to b minus football from lamar jackson
strictly as a pocket quarterback and i'm
not saying he would be b to b minus but
to me if you take away the run from
lamar jackson you're taking away part of
the game that makes him
one of the most incredibly dangerous
weapons in football
but see this narrative's been there from
the moment he became the starter hey
this is going to be great while it lasts
and it's not going to last long well
it's lasted it lasted through the 2019
season after he became the starter in
2018 he was the mvp last year it lasted
through 2020 he's able to pull it off
and in a single elimination setting
you're even less inclined to be careful
you've got the whole off season to heal
yeah you're chasing greatness so he's
going to be even more aggressive let's
hear from the man himself earlier this
week lamar jackson talking about how he
has been and surely will be more
aggressive in the postseason
just on my mindset um just you know
attacking the game more being more
aggressive you know um i'll say by the
beginning this even beginning of the
season i was conservative a lot you know
just standing back uh and getting set a
lot more you know but you know as the
season went on you know things break
down um my first read out there second
reason is not there you know i take
advantage of what the defense gives me
um that's pretty much the biggest thing
and you know we just been finishing like
all around on the whole offensive
defense uh especially teams you know all
of us just been finishing so that's part
of the biggest thing about you know just
coming back from quarantine the whole
team is just died damn right now
peter you mentioned the weather earlier
the dark sky app tells me that at game
time tomorrow night it will be 34
degrees on the way to 36 temperature
actually going up no precipitation
expected tomorrow night so that's good
news for the ravens as they hope for a
dry and fast track as they try to run
through and around the buffalo bills
defense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports